So you finish writing your app
and it's ready to go, right?
It might not be.
Have you heard of
performance theory,
and how to check that
your app is at its best?
My name is Joanna Smith.
And I'm here to introduce
you to the performance tuning
lifecycle, so that
you will know when,
and how, to optimize your app.
The truth is that
most developers
don't think about performance
until it has already
become a problem.
Which, of course, usually
happens when you're up
against a deadline,
the coffee is gone,
and there's a weird man smell
lingering in the office.
But in times like
these, keep calm.
Don't panic.
Because fixing
performance problems
is straightforward with the
performance tuning lifecycle.
There's only three steps.
Gather, insight, and action.
Even if you've found
your performance problem,
it may not be immediately
clear what is triggering it.
And that brings us to phase
1, gathering information.
The easiest way
for you to do that
is to use a tool that
gathers the data for you.
Now most tools are built
for a specific purpose.
Some are specialized for memory
information or GPU performance
or battery usage.
All this means is that
you'll most likely
need to run several different
tools in order to figure out
what's really going on.
The key to success here
is knowing which tool
to use to understand what data.
So you know where in
your app to look so
that you can fix your problem.
But once you have
all of that data,
do you know how to read it?
Most of the time you're
going to be stuck
with a bunch of
numbers or lines,
or just junk that
looks like Greek.
So now comes phase
2, gaining insight.
When it comes down
to it, you're trying
to identify your problem out
of a whole bunch of nonsense.
So you might rely on these tools
to help you format the data
and make it readable.
But even then, you need to
understand what it means.
And how it applies to your app.
For example, Heap Viewer may
look really intimidating.
But knowing how to read it
will help you realize that all
you're seeing here
are bitmap objects
lingering on the heap
across activity transitions.
And now you've got
something you can work on.
Now unfortunately, steps
1 and 2 aren't linear.
They're circular.
This means that sometimes you'll
open a tool, grab some data,
interpret it, and that'll
just lead you to another tool.
Consider Traceview,
which may show you
a horde of garbage
collection events occurring
during your scroll event.
The insight here
is that something
is going crazy with memory.
Which means that you can switch
over to the Allocation Tracker,
and see what's
causing all the fuss.
So by the time you reach phase
3, you might be kind of tired.
But take a breath.
Because this step is
often the hardest.
Taking action.
This is where you
will move past all
of those numbers and insights
to actually go fix your problem.
But be careful.
Performance fixes
aren't just about code.
Of the three stages,
this the most human.
Because solving the
problem isn't enough.
You need to solve
it in a way that
meets your coding standards
and your design constraints,
and can be done
under a deadline.
So make sure that you have
a plan before you run off
and fix things.
But now you're done.
Congrats!
JK, you guys.
Because as long as
your application
is even a bit wonky, you'll be
going through this lifecycle
over and over and over again
on various parts of your code
base.
To get your app
truly running smooth,
every single piece needs to
be optimized for performance.
And that's why you should check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns
resources to help
you know what tools to
use, what they mean,
and how to solve your problems.
And don't forget to join the
Google+ community, as well.
Because you can get insight
from other folks who've already
had these problems.
So keep calm.
Profile your code.
And always remember,
perf matters.